vocês se lembram um do primeiro dia de
colégio de vocês a minha memória é um
mix de sensações
eu lembro que estava saindo de uma pré
escola era muito pequena de bairro e
onde todo mundo se conhecia e e de
repente eu fui transferido netinho que
mudar para um colégio muito grande que
me levaria do ensino fundamental até o
vestibular em todo esse processo que ia
passar e eu lembro bem do dia assim
algumas coisas eu lembro de chegar com
segurando a mão da minha mãe e minha mãe
passar a minha a minha mão para uma
outra pessoa que eu não conhecia tão bem
e morder andando pelo colégio
andando pelos corredores que já não eram
os meus corredores andando é vendo as
crianças que já não eram os meus colegas
assim a criança grande tinha criança
outros tipos de crianças vendo as salas
e de repente entra numa sala que não é a
minha
sendo uma carteira que não é a minha com
colegas que não são os meus eu não
conheço eles ea professora que não é a
minha
chega lá se apresenta e começa a
carimbar o caderno de todas as crianças
nada era meu a única coisa que era minha
para vocês terem uma ideia era minha
mochila e nela material que era um
material novo então nem aquilo que
conhecia direito e quando ela quer em
boa os cadernos depois ela falou assim
eu olhei era um carimbo do macaco e daí
ela falou ok criança agora vocês vão
pintar o macaco não peguem seus lápis de
cores vão colorir um macaco
pela primeira vez eu estava seguro
porque eu já tinha feito isso antes já
tinha feito isso no colégio anterior eu
sabia pegar uma caixa de lápis de cor e
pintar o que eu fiz
tirei uma caixa faber castell 36 cores
da mochila e colocar em cima da mesa
peguei aquele caderno olhei e fui
tirando o corpor cor lápis por lapso e
fui pintando macaco
eu comecei pelo rabo e fui escolhendo
todas as cores e fazendo um macaco mais
colorido que tinha visto na minha vida
eu fui pelo rabo pé
o tronco braços o macaco estava ficando
supercolorido estava quase terminando no
pescoço dele a professora chegou a olhão
ou e falou assim ah meu deus o que é
isso
não existe uma carga colorido macaca é
marrom cinza ou preto faça de novo
é doloroso né e eu lembro assim que é
super doloroso para a criança
óbvio é doloroso para a escola que acaba
perdendo o propósito de em algum momento
ele é doloroso para a sociedade que vai
perder talvez o máximo do potencial de
algumas pessoas
e o pior é muito doloroso é horrível
professora porque provavelmente ela não
quando ela escolheu ser professora não
era aquilo que estava escolhendo todo
mundo escolhe seu professor a escolher
professores simplesmente porque acredita
que aquilo pode transformar o mundo
acredita que aquele papel que não é um
papel de ganhar muito dinheiro não é um
papel de ter um sucesso absurdo um papel
extremamente valioso que tem propósito e
pode transformar as coisas mas acontece
alguma coisa dentro do processo
educacional que pega esses professores
coloca eles num outro patamar
num patamar num outro mais de 7 no
último modelo mental deixou de ser
aquele modelo mental da transformação
que é fantástico e coloca ele no modelo
mental simplesmente do conteúdo
aquele modelo mental em que ele vai
olhar
ele vai ver qual é o conteúdo que ele é
obrigado a passar ele vai ver qual é a
pessoa pegou aquele conteúdo ele vai
encontrar uma maneira de avaliar isso
esse é o papel dele então de repente
aquele desenho do macaco deixa de ser um
macaco completamente colorido e acaba
virando ok
é isso que tem que ser feito hoje pintar
uma casa ea gente vai olhar o nosso
processo de educação e tem muito disso
nele você vai olhar como funciona o
colégio você vai ver que a gente aprende
o que é um objeto direto que é um
sujeito predicado mas a gente acaba não
aprendem a interpretar um texto
e você vê que
sessenta por cento talvez mais da
população brasileira adulta não consegue
interpretar um texto ea gente vai vendo
isso acontecer em várias esferas da
educação as vença esse mais sete do
conteúdo essa obrigação pelo conteúdo e
subvertendo o que é muito importante que
é uma indústria de transformação por que
isso acontece
isso acontece porque quando a gente
quando surgiu esse modelo de educação
ele nasceu é ele nasceu num outro
momento ela nasceu num momento de
revolução industrial em que você precisa
produzir pessoas que fossem operar uma
máquina então era muito comum era muito
natural que você pegasse uma pessoa você
sabia que ela estaria fazendo ali há 50
anos
você pegar você colocava lá pra você
operar essa máquina ou para você entrar
e vivendo essa sociedade
você vai ter que aprender essas regras
você vai ter que aprender esses
conteúdos e depois que você sair disso
você tá pronto você vai se virar e na
maioria das etapas da sua vida e eu
aprendi super bem aquela lição que eu
acabei esquecendo se lembrar alguns anos
atrás eu apreendi um super bem como que
eu sei porque eu sempre tinha nada boa e
sempre me dei muito bem sempre me
adaptei perfeitamente à escola até o
final
então o que propõe propõe que a gente
volte e volte a pensar no que a oma em 7
da transformação o que a gente está
fazendo quando a gente querendo virar
professor e isso é uma coisa urgente
porque agora o que a gente está vendo
aqui esse modelo de educação da
revolução industrial quando ele se choca
com o que a gente tá vivendo hoje que
esse mundo de transformação em que o
professor olha o aluno e ele não sabe
que vai ser desse aluno daqui a dez anos
o aluno não sabe que vai ser dele é
supernatural de entrar na faculdade e
você não saber o que vai ser da sua
profissão logo que você sair
isso aconteceu comigo é então quais são
os conteúdos que a gente tem que
aprender
essa é a pergunta e daí essa mudança de
cima em 7
ele é é uma urgência a gente sabe disso
mas ao mesmo tempo é uma uma coisa que a
gente ainda não sabe como fazer
exatamente assim o mundo tá muito
patinando nisso é a única notícia boa
único fato bom que eu acho que já é
fantástico é esse aqui a nossa geração
eu vocês essa discussão que está
acontecendo aqui
essa é a primeira vez na história da
humanidade que a gente está discutindo
isso uma maneira extremamente ampla eu
passo por sala de professor
e é isso que está se discutindo a esse
modelo de educação que está vivendo hoje
não se encaixa perfeitamente não
funciona muito bem esse processo é de
educação os alunos é tão entrando nesse
colapso os professores entram em colapso
todo mundo percebendo esse processo
colapsando é ea gente sabe que precisa
mudar
então nós estamos muito perto de mudar
só que será que ele não vai encontrar
este caminho
será que globalmente a gente não vai
conseguir encontrar qual é essa solução
que a gente precisa fazer e tem sim
algumas coisas fantásticas que estão
acontecendo no mundo que quando eu olho
eu falo tem um aprendizado aí talvez
esse seja um caminho que pode ser
seguido por exemplo uma iniciativa
chamada kiss hack day iniciativa que
transforma crianças e pessoas que
utilizam tecnologia para resolver
problemas
ela não simplesmente coloca o ipad na
sala de aula mas ela ensina a usar
tecnologia para resolver problemas que
causa uma transformação absurda ou uma
iniciativa que eu tive a oportunidade de
conhecer na indonésia que agride school
que é uma escola onde no primeiro dia de
aula o professor vai chegar para as
crianças falam assim que vocês querem o
que vocês querem fazer esse ano e elas
vão falar assim eu quero construir uma
casa de fado e que o professor vai falar
assim legal do que vocês precisam e eles
falam que é absurda a transformação que
você percebe quando você não diz uma
pessoa que ela não pode fazer aquilo
dentro dos casos deles eles têm
histórias de crianças que conseguiram
mudar uma lei simplesmente porque eles
perguntando o que ela poderia fazer para
transformar é ou ainda uma coisa super
simples o business model canvas
quem conhece é um pedaço de papel desse
tamanho em que você consegue usar quase
todas as teorias da administração de uma
maneira extremamente prática e você
consegue modelar um negócio inteiro uma
empresa inteira num papel com os chips
isso é fantástico porque conecta você é
novo porque para onde você quer chegar e
não simplesmente o conteúdo pelo
conteúdo e eu faço parte também de uma
iniciativa que eu entendo que é eu
gostaria muito que ela estivesse eu
entendo que ela está contribuindo para
esse universo educação eu faço parte de
uma iniciativa aqui de curitiba que ela
serve para que as pessoas percebam e
aprendam a ser grandes mestres na arte
de viver e encontrar a felicidade
então a gente trabalha há anos na maior
parte das nossas iniciativas com adultos
ea gente ensina empoderamento pessoal
para eles através de estratégias
educacionais que a gente considera
inovadoras e porque a gente considera
inovadoras é quando a gente recebe esse
tipo de briefing e às vezes a gente
recebe de de pessoas comuns na nossa
sede
a gente recebe de empresas a gente
recebe um monte de lugar é a gente olha
aquilo e tenta mapear ok
como é a vida da pessoa antes dessa
estratégia educacional desse processo
educacional
como é ver como vai ser a vida dela
depois se eu não encontrar diferença
nesse mapa
eu não tenho educação eu não tenho um
produto tem um eu vou jogar conteúdos
mas eu não vou de transformação
então a gente começa a mapear isso e
algumas coisas fantásticas começa a
acontecer a gente começa a prestar
atenção só nisso na transformação
algumas coisas ainda o conteúdo outra
centro
talvez saia conteúdo entre histórias
talvez o conteúdo fique porque ele é
realmente importante talvez entre
ferramentas mas não começa a olhar isso
aqui
a transformação transformar o objeto
direto sujeito predicado na habilidade
de interpretar uma poesia transformar o
bing 3,14 15
fez no poder de construir uma roda de
bicicleta
esse é o ponto fundamental que a gente
acaba esquecendo como professores e para
isso a gente acabou internamente criando
uma ferramenta zinho que é um câmbio
suba um pedaço de papel
quando a gente uma peia no lado esquerdo
é como a vida da pessoa antes do nosso
processo educacional no direito como é a
vida da pessoa que ela sente como que a
rotina dela que ela faz o que ela pensa
que a gente começa a olhar para ver se
aquela coisa realmente uma experiência
transformadora ea gente começa a
entender qual é a grande transformação
que a gente tem que oferecer em cada
aula e e as experiências que têm tido
são muito legais assim por exemplo é ter
uma vez que a gente recebeu um professor
de psicologia e ele e quando ele chegou
para montar o curso ele ele falou né
então eu quero ensinar e umg eu quero
ensinar o edital o básico de cada um
desses agentes ele foi explicando isso à
nossa isso é fantástico muito legal
vamos fazer isso mas antes vamos só
colocar uns positivos aqui nesse campo
para a gente entender qual o que vai ser
o curso começou 30 minutos ele colocou
um post
depois ele vira pra gente fala meu curso
não é de psicologia meu curso é como ter
relacionamentos melhores percebem a
transformação ea gente chega é a gente
recebe um pedido do departamento de rh
da empresa para um treinamento
corporativo e a gente eles já sabem que
eles querem mas a gente fala assim a
beleza mas que legal só vamos colocar os
positivos aqui e de repente eles olham a
então não era é que na verdade não quero
que ele treinamento eu tinha falado eu
quero um treinamento de comunicação
interna a gente reduzir o conflito legal
e e mais maluco
desde que começou a usar isso na
comunicação ou seja a pessoa que faz a
comunicação olha isso e ver a
transformação a gente conseguir o
engajamento absurdo de aluno porque a
pessoa olha a descrição do produto na
hora da comunicação e fala é isso que eu
quero é que eu não quero mas a pessoa
chega de cid e se ela chegar ela está
satisfeita ela vai ter a experiência que
ela
funciona muito legal pra gente é muito
legal e daí ficou essa pergunta se essa
dor absurda é da do mundo precisando
dessa transformação
nós com uma ferramenta interna que a
gente pensou será que é possível
será que será que outras pessoas
precisariam disso é que outras pessoas
poderiam se beneficiar disso
e daí eu faço parte de uma comunidade do
fórum econômico mundial chamada global
shapers e nessa comunidade tem muita
gente interessada por educação no mundo
inteiro e eu fiz um call com essas
pessoas fez um chamado e pedi para eles
apresentei o projeto explique como é que
a gente fazia tal e de repente uma
menina que trabalha com treinamento de
professores na jamaica
olhou e falou assim nossa e seria muito
legal para usar os meus professores um
cara que trabalha no governo do tibete
falou assim eu acho que eu podia usar
isso para a gente desenvolver nossas
políticas públicas de educação em outro
carro que representa o maior grupo de
escolas afeganistão falou
será que eu posso usar isso para
planejar as aulas que a gente quer ter
aqui usar isso para a nossa nossa grade
curricular e daí foi na hora que a gente
falou assim caramba isso pode ser uma
solução que vai ajudar a colocar uma
incerta transformação do mundo a gente
perceber um mercado absurdamente grande
talvez treinar you é a gente percebeu
que era uma dor absurdamente grande todo
mundo está discutindo isso ea gente
começou a pensar em possibilidades de
expansão e como é que a gente poderia
fazer pra esse camas para esse produto
se expandir para caramba ea gente a uma
conclusão não é de um produto que a
gente precisa
então nós estamos abrindo o campo mas
vou pensar se nós estamos abrindo ele
para que qualquer pessoa possa usar sob
licença creative commons então você pode
usar você pode oferecer feedback e você
pode experimentar das mais variadas
maneiras
a gente entende que essa é a maneira que
você pode causar a transformação do
mundo e que sim
essa transformação precisa muito ser
global
o que eu espero
tudo é que o mundo tenha uma idéia da
transformação e se esses campos puder
ajudar alguém eu vou ficar muito feliz é
muito obrigado pela atenção